et on va parler insomnies avec vous
judas stieger bonjour julien oui car
l'insomnie serait en forte augmentation
depuis le début de la pandémie de co
vide un phénomène constaté en france
ainsi qu'à l'étranger cela concerne tant
les personnes précédemment affectés par
le cos vide que ceux n'ayant pas été
infectés vous nous en dit plus c'est ce
que les revues scientifiques
excusez moi on parle même de nouveau
vers la somme niasse et ça exactement
dix ans de covin sommes ni arbitres
souvenir exactement ils ont créé un
nouveau terme justement c'est l'insomnie
c'est considéré comme l'un à des
symptômes les plus récurrents dus qu'aux
villes l'ont justement avec les
faiblesses musculaires mais aussi avec
la fatigue importante et on estime
aujourd'hui que environ 10 à 30 % des
personnes qui ont contracté le kobe 19
souffre aujourd'hui d'une affection
longue une autre étude c'est une
compilation en fait des études qui ont
été faites à l'international estime que
avoir été contaminés par le coc u19
augmenterait les chances de souffrir
d'insomnie d'environ 37% alors il faut
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui on ne connaît
pas les causes du coc vide l'eau et donc
de ses symptômes associés mais on sait
que par exemple chez les personnes qui
ont eu qui ont justement ce qu vie dont
on a trouvé ce qu'on appelle des
réservoir viral c'est à dire on retrouve
en fait de la rn messager du coût du
service cause de dans différents tissus
et différents organes ouvriers dans la
thyroïde dans l'oesophage
et voilà on retrouve ça un petit peu
partout alors une piste qui expliquerait
justement notamment les insomnies c'est
le fait que une infection hausse à
roscoff 2 va complètement déréglé ce
qu'on appelle le mot le microbiote
intestinal alors c'est quoi exactement
est bien c'est un ensemble de micro
organismes qui est logé aujourd'hui dans
votre tube digestif et qui comprend plus
de cent mille milliards de bactéries il
y en a des bonnes il y en a des moins
bonnes mais c'est un écosystème en fait
extrêmement intelligent on dit souvent
d'ailleurs que c'est un deuxième cerveau
pourquoi parce que eh bien grâce à tout
cet écosystème et 7 sa manière de
fonctionner ça va notamment augmenter
votre système immunitaire ça va vous
permettre de combattre certains
pathogènes et ça va aussi vous permettre
de mieux dormir pourquoi parce que ça
envoie en fait des signaux à votre
cerveau c'est pour ça qu'on dit que
c'est un un second cerveau ça va vous
dire par exemple d'aller vous coucher et
donc certaines études ont constaté
qu'effectivement les personnes qui
avaient été infectés par le coc u19
avait un microbiote intestinal qui était
donc perturbé donc c'est pour ça que ce
signal ne se fait pas en fait avec le
cerveau pour pouvoir dormir et à
linverse aussi certaines personnes qui
avaient déjà avant l'infection un
microbiote intestinal qui n'était pas
diversifié ont développé des cas plus
sévères de kobe de 19 alors ce que
révèlent les les chercheurs aussi c'est
que ses problèmes d'insomnie ne concerne
pas seulement les personnes qui ont eu
qu à vide mais aussi
les personnes qui ont mal vécu cette
cette pandémie absolument la population
générale en fait au delà des infections
les confinements successives par exemple
vous le savez ont entraîné moins
d'interactions sociales moins de sport
plus de temps d'écran plus de stress de
deux siestes excusez moi pendant la
journée et pour d'autres évidemment du
de l'anxiété du stress et de la solitude
et tout cela sont évidemment des
facteurs qui entraînent beaucoup
d'anxiété et donc des insomnies alors la
crise en fait du coït 19 a rompu ce que
l'on appelle nos rythmes circadiens ce
sont des rythmes et des cycles si vous
voulez de plus ou moins 24 heures sur
lesquels tous vos organes sont son son
câble et donc il fonctionne sur ces
rythmes de 24 heures et ces dérèglements
du sommeil on les constate notamment en
france mais aussi partout ailleurs à
l'étranger au delà du coc vis de la
france était déjà championne en en
termes d'insomnie avec une personne sur
trois qui souffrent de ces troupes de
l'endormissement oui effectivement
sachant aussi qu'il ya plus de 11,5
millions de personnes en france qui
utilisent des somnifères de manière
régulière alors la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'il ya des moyens plus naturel est
d'essayer de lutter je vais vous donner
quelques conseils peut-être si vous
souffrez d'insomnie mais il faut déjà se
préparer à aller se coucher c'est un
rituel qu'il faut créer on va pas juste
se coucher comme ça par exemple pourquoi
pas faire une bonne douche chaude ou
même un bain de pieds avec du sel ça
peut vraiment vous aider à vous mettre
dans l'ambiance il faut privilégier les
heures de coucher et de lever beaucoup
plus régulier pour essayer justement de
régler cette horloge interne faire de
l'exercice évidemment pas en soirée plus
tôt en journée environ 30 minutes par
jour c'est suffisant et éviter
évidemment de consommer des excitants
comme le café ou encore la nicotine
après 15 heures enfin essayer de
favoriser un 10 un dîner léger là ça va
un peu à l'encontre de tout ce qu'on
peut tout ce qu'on nous a dit par le
passé mais de préférence à base de
glucides lents c'est à dire les pommes
de terre les pâtes le riz ou encore le
pain et éviter de manger deux heures
avant d'aller se coucher et si vraiment
on lutte pour s'endormir on peut tenter
les couvertures lester qu'est ce que
c'est exactement alors les couvertures
laisse t on les appelle aussi des
découvertes surpondérer voilà ce sont en
fait des couvertures qui sont beaucoup
plus lourdes elles peuvent peser entre 6
et 15 kg et ce qu'elles vont faire c'est
qu'elles vont exercer un poids non
seulement sur vos muscles mais aussi sur
vos articulations et donc ça va vous
donner une sensation d'être protégé
d'être
cercle est en fête et ça va vous aider à
dormir plus plus vite et en tout cas
d'avoir moins d'anxiété enfin un remède
de grand mère mais qui a été confirmée
cette fois ci très récemment par des
études scientifiques
la fleur d'oranger aurait en fait d d un
pouvoir contre contre l'anxiété assez
incroyable et serait d'ailleurs plus
efficace qu un anxiolytique classique
pour justement réduire l'anxiété donc
tisane à la fleur d'oranger exacte d'un
matisse riz orientale à la fleur
d'oranger après une petite douche chaude
c'est voilà c'est pas merci pour tous
ces conseils julia siggers merci à vous
c'était le billet science